so chelsea
have you drunk kissed someone whilst
being in a relationship with matthew
maybe how long have you back been
together uh almost two years
later have you done that as well no
as i said yep
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm phil
johnson your host and i'm with one two
funny this guy is gonna be the judge
jewellery and executioner relationship
goals is a tournament where coppers go
head to head to see who's got the most
solid couple if they win this they go to
the semi-final if they win at the
semi-final they go to the final and if
they win the final
golden ruby
even though this money you know but more
importantly as my judges demonstrated
they win 100 free firewave pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
emma's friends from time to go i'm
saying just hold it up
i'm going to try blowing in the tires
switch open that anyway let's go i am
glad to be back but if you say anything
bad i won't be glad to be here i'm not
gonna lie
listen i've got this in the bag we'll be
all right i'm looking forward to finding
out any secrets that you might have
we did well last time so hopefully we
can do the same this time let's see i'm
really excited i think we got this
i'm still nervous about the questions i
don't know what to expect yeah they're
always answering the questions yeah
after last week there were good
questions so i'm thinking
i think it's gonna get worse
it's gonna get worse
[Music]
for the first round you guys are going
to fill in the blanks of what you think
your misses will say
so ladies i'm going to need you to go in
the soundproof section
so i can have a little chat with you
fellas
feeling confident today
humble but confident you know humble but
confident
i think hopefully i'll be all right no
i'm saying you're all right yeah all
right question one
i used to be way more enthusiastic about
blank
with him than i am now what do you think
your girlfriend would have said oh
i'm gonna go with leyton first so what's
usually like at the start of the
relationship
oh listen
she was jarring about this okay okay i
know every girl
loves their date nights but amanda
wanted them every day of the week bro
but now she's relaxed i feel like she's
just cold she's like she's chill so
listen i'm saying eight nights bro
because she used to be like so when we
got on date night
okay
matthew
um
you repeat the question again
listen
listen carefully i know you smoked a lot
of weed this morning
i used to be way more enthusiastic about
blank
with him than i am now
no pressure
i'd say maybe
go in cinema watching a film yeah okay
all right
that's decent
himself for his dead answer
i'm only with him for his blank without
that i'd be gone
i'm gonna go for matthew you want me to
repeat the question matthew
i thought so i'm only with him for his
blank without that i've begun
support
that one you see how he felt like he was
deep with it yes
poor man
you guys are going to think this is mad
but it'd rather be my cousin because
it's more than a friend no no no no no
no no
when we're first going out in it was in
uni met in uni
and
me and her would not be together
i'm not saying that i don't have no game
no it's the fact that he helped me out
like we had this like car journey where
she was um we was on the phone to her
and he was just kind of patting enough
for me so she literally chatting to her
and i'm like you're sitting there yeah
yeah you guys gassing me up somebody
yesterday
same like i don't i didn't have to say a
thing
he's like he's got gaming
man's out here chilling with hitch and
that's right
i do have game just let you know but
i was a bit nervous
question three even though
i love my girlfriend
my ex
blank is the better
blank
and i'm going to go with layton
why me blob i don't even know what to
say you know
because i'll just say something easy
okay
you go fruit
okay let's not repeat that too loud even
though i love my girlfriend
my active mouth gave the better head
mouth head
head we'll put a head mouth and head
okay okay
yes well done i'm getting there before
later because normally very slow but you
must be really passionate about your
ex's head anyway
okay i'll say
i don't know how to make it make sense
but like
awesome again it so makes his asses
bigger so i know what you're saying so
even though i love my girlfriend my ex's
ass
is the better bunda oh so why are you
just saying like that this thing sounds
mad
ladies can we have the ladies back
please are you guys ready to
see what they said
no
okay so
for question one i told you boyfriends
to fill in this blank
i used to be way more enthusiastic about
blank with him than i am now
what do you think he answered and amanda
i'm gonna go to you first
well okay
i used to
at the start of the relationship i used
to bang on about us gone on dates
little date nights or whatever and they
would never happen so two years down the
line i'm over it and i don't care if
we're gonna date or not i'm not gonna
lie
my standards have dropped
chels i think my answer is pretty
similar you know spending time with each
other
like outside you know going on dates and
stuff okay would you like to be more
specific
seeing each other more often than we
used to would you say date nights scenic
even more often or go into a specific
place seeing each other more often the
first answers are in and
used to
have passed with flying colors and yep
as you can imagine years to fail
so for question two
i asked your boyfriend
i'm only with him for his blank
without that i would be gone
all right i'm gonna go with chelsea
first can we have an answer please
um
i must say
his car
oh
oh he's about to say something else
he said his car what'd you drive my
lamborghini
cool you're mad amanda you're mad lazy
i'm gonna repeat the question
i'm only with him for his
blank
without that i'd be gone i feel like
since last time you did this and it
worked i'm gonna do it again okay
getting the answer from you
okay
maybe we should have done that yeah um
when we first met
he was too [ __ ] to speak to me so
he basically got someone else to
chat
to me so we'd be together which was his
family member what family member
um so it was this
his cousin called kyrie
and i kid you not we had like an hour
and a half long conversation on the
phone i i wasn't speaking to leighton
speaking to his cousin and somehow he's
now my boyfriend the answers are in
and
you guys
you guys are passing with flying colors
you guys are on heat yeah
and the guy is shaking their head in the
corner look
you know what's sick here
these guys are also synchronized because
they both know at the same time when
they lose so the answer was yep cousin
and he went really deep with it oh he
said you're with him for his
support
now i get that he you was with him for
him to support him
exactly that's what i'm saying
i thought i'd ask him something about
him
and how he feels
and let you guys fill in the blacks i'm
not saying any names but one of these
guys is in the doghouse woofie all right
are you ready to hear the question
even though i love my girlfriend
my ex is blank
is the better blank
amanda first
okay
well it's definitely not lux
okay wow
i want to say her attitude is better
than mine because mind bad
awkward okay so so i have to go wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
amanda before you kill anybody
even though
even though i love my girlfriend
my ex's attitude is the better attitude
that's what you want to say yeah got the
a right but anyway
okay
chelsea
you really need to remember this
love he said even though he loves you
remember that key word love i'm not
gonna remember that later i know you're
not gonna remember that but i have to
say
even though i love my girlfriend my ex
is blank is the better blank i must say
kissing
okay what's the x's name just first
names please sarah sarah so you're gonna
be like my ex sarah is the better kisser
yeah yeah we're gonna go with that cool
i'm gonna give
you guys the answer first
so as i said you got the a right he was
he was very close because he said my
exes ass
is the
because you said attitude but the
correct answer was attitude
yeah yeah you're not going to talk to
the guys in the back about that in a
minute are you okay amanda we're good
sometimes love is not enough
ouch
okay
i'm dreading this now bro matthew said i
just leave him get his microphone
properly
yeah
that's what matt said
ah you might do me dirty
no you did
you did yourself
right even though i love my girlfriend
my ex's mouth gives the better head
that's what your um boyfriend said
i'm actually okay with that
i'm not disclosing any information
but i'm just saying you're gonna have a
long chat so i just want to say amanda's
personality is 110
more bang in my house okay but now that
she said pursued that's good
oh my attitude is gonna come out i'm not
gonna worry about that okay why did
everyone say that
this is an open space this is a safe
you're lucky to be in here right now
i'll come question yeah so if i would
have said what matthew said where would
it be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
girls are you ready to get some payback
yes all right cool
are you guys ready yeah
first question
if we wear
my boyfriend would be a blank in the
bedroom i'm going to go with chelsea
first
i'm going to say
a cheetah
because he's fast
not fast like that but like she
so you're describing these times in the
bedroom without you is that what's
happening here i'm just trying to figure
it i'm just trying to make sure the
maths is math
yeah the math says
what do you think amanda
um
i could say something really mean just
to get back at him i think he should you
should but i want the point so i'm not
going to do that i'm going to say a lion
what was you going to say out of
curiosity
rabbit when they do that
yeah i don't watch rabbit porn sorry
anyway
question two
if my boyfriend blanks again
i'm gone
i'm gonna go with chelsea no why
i hate it here
if it takes long to reply
his reply game is weak so in that time
that he replies do you think he's out
there being exact yeah
how long does it take
a long time hours
amanda
um i'll repeat the question yeah go on
them
if my boyfriend blanks
again i'll be gone
if he argues with me in public
again
i'm gone so on the night out picture
this one our night out we're leaving to
go home it's the end of the night he's
overstayed is welcome at the club it's
like 4 30 now we want to get home
waiting for an uber we argue about uber
prices
is he saying you have to pay because
you've forced him to leave early no he
just he's dingy he doesn't want to pay
so he's stingy he wants me to pay
he wants you to when i don't want to go
clubbing oh so you're anyway you're only
even there because of him yes oh wow so
yeah if you're there because of him he
has to pay yeah let him know i said that
question three
when i first saw my boyfriend's
blank
i was extremely disappointed
i don't know what's so funny
amanda i'm gonna let you go first
because i picked on chelsea it doesn't
disappoint me doll
it's all good to say that but you have
to give an answer
just say what you can see in your head
because i can see you see and i can see
you look away
okay i'm gonna say
when he argues his he's like
very
nasty
foul-mouthed so when you first saw your
brother
dark side yeah
dark side let's go with that
um
i'm gonna say
his chest
his chest his chest shoulders yeah
they're kind of small
are you saying that your boyfriend is
not a slender man
maybe
so are you saying if your boyfriend
got punched in his chest
he's not a dog
can we have the mandem back please
all right before i go
and we get into this round i just want
to say
if you've been with us so far you might
as well carry on with us by clicking
like commenting and subscribing to
standout tv yes and before we carry on
just remember what's in it for them they
can win 1 000 pounds
and 100 free
fire away pizzas no way bro way bro way
has been blown
for question one
i asked your girlfriend
if we were animals
my boyfriend would be um
if we were animals
my boyfriend would be a blank in the
bedroom
are you okay man
matthew what are you meant to answer
oh no
you're not on a game show you're just at
home
this is all a part of your imagination
you normally got i'm gonna go with you
fuzz okay matthew i'm going to go with
you
first i'm going to repeat the question
as well because i know that's what you
need if we were animals my boyfriend
would be a blank in the bedroom
don't she can't save you my guy
jesus got the eagle in there right you
see the way
no no
i'll repeat the question for you
leighton
if we were animals sir
my boyfriend would be a blank
in the bedroom see ya i don't want to be
a copy in that box i have to say i'm
lying you're not insane
i have to be aligned i have to be alive
i have to be if she says it comes out
something like a rabbit or something i
don't know what to say
usually i'm mad in sync you know but
i'll get her later one of yous
was a lion
and the other one
wasn't
[Laughter]
amanda
said
lions
come on let's go chelsea on the other
hand
said cheetah
because of how fast you are and disloyal
but you know how do you feel about that
matthew you're just lying
leave it on to question two if my
boyfriend
blanks again
i'm gone
personally i don't think i've done
anything yet
so
if you stop my guy man the man said yet
the honesty is the honesty for me
well with that reaction i think i got
this wrong but i was going to say cheat
and then it but i'm not i haven't done
it yet
no black dog
i'm not saying
if my boyfriend blanks again he's
already done it i'll be gone
um probably like a massive argument or
sorting something like that like i have
like a
mad outrage argument so i don't know
okay argument i agree yeah i agree
hi guys
how's the mouths doing over there i must
have been a hard one to swallow
okay we are on fire today fire away
pizza that's crazy jesus yes i'm going
to repeat the question because i know
you need it slow oh no no i got the
question oh you got it yeah you're with
it
we kind of had a chat about this
whilst on the way here oh wow so
with the lamborghini yeah yeah yeah so
basically
if we're on the same page
to get here today we had to wake up at
half three in the morning she and about
getting up early
we repeat the question one more time
went down to shepparton and then came
all the way back to the end i said hey
oh wait hold on hey what flipping
everyone say what did you say again
if my boyfriend blanks
again
i'll be gone
keyword again for layton's
this early in the morning
that's what you want to say bro that
means you wouldn't even have to come to
the final do you even want to win sober
up a little bit
and then think about
what your girl would say
be serious bro no because i don't even
know because like have you cheated
oh my god
no wait stop stop stop stop stop are you
happy in your relationship yeah yes you
are yeah
[Music]
can it be happier
so have you cheated on chelsea
define
[Applause]
yes
obviously if you're out with the boys
had a couple drinks whatever
you go out partying whatever i don't
know some girls chatting to you two plus
two equals four you get me no i don't
get you oh okay you're saying i didn't
know you knew
that you're like ah like you kind of
clocked like i should have done whatever
oh so you you drunk kiss someone
yeah
and did you go for a
clearly not
clearly not so
sick
it was a while ago
100 no you did not
but it's okay i forgive you oh you do
yeah
chelsea
are you okay yeah i'm okay don't worry
haven't you eaten mafia no
this is not about me this is his
question why are you asking me
i'm not deflecting i'm just saying
this is his question
chelsea
this this is not relationship counseling
i'm just saying get hot in here
have you
cheated
on matthew
i mean like in the same sense as him
that he's coming from
so like if that's what we're talking
about then
what are you talking about
[Music]
what's going on have you drunk kissed
someone whilst being in a relationship
with matthew
maybe how long have you stacked been
together oh almost two years
wow
have you done that as well
as i said
so for the record neither you guys knew
about each other's cheating
until right now
i didn't know
i love how they're so nonchalant about
it
i guess some things are better left in
the post
you can't dwell on your mistakes you can
only improve on them
you can't change the past you can only
change the future chelsea that's where
you work on yourself and you become a
better person well for the question two
we're going to go with cheat
you said cheat and you actually meant it
chelsea thought take long to reply
that's all you see what that's literally
massive argument
your girlfriend said
public argument i can't give you the
point there
so the last question
we asked
when i first saw my boyfriend's blank i
was extremely disappointed
what do you think this could
be i'm gonna go
with
leighton first
i'm gonna say hairline
i don't know probably my hairline
because my forehead is kind of big now
i'm saying so so he said hairline and
matthew
when i first saw my boyfriend's blank i
was extremely disappointed
huh room room yeah oh you wanna learn
messy use 50 50. i've got good days
about bad days but more time the room is
just like then he has good days and
today
long day
long decade very long day
all right so the answers are in for this
i'm going to keep this short and sweet
your girlfriend said
dark side
so basically you've got a bit of a
temper on you sometimes you get a bit
nasty that's what she's saying when you
argue you get a bit nasty forehead is
still big but you also get nasty
but you my friend
is it's not on the big side it's more of
their non-existence
that was a good one i'm so sorry about
yours again
because your girlfriend said when i
first saw my boyfriend's pathetic chest
i did not say that i was extremely
disappointed
not at the chest oh my god
baby boy those are not my words and look
matthew you see this you see that see
the way the logo is moving bro
i'm not gonna lie i actually was gonna
say room judge could we have the scores
please okay for round two uh very funny
round call blimey i can say overall
on this side
around the relation you got one point
and on
[Laughter]
i don't know that side let's just call
it that side you have been failing with
flying quality
the overall scores are
three points to amanda and layton
and uh
zero squared to you
guys the couple that's going through is
amanda and layton
yeah
congratulations okay
that's been relationship goals guys and
amanda and lay and are going to be
joining us in the finals i hope you join
us too like and subscribe for the
notifications are you okay
[Music]
um
let's just say we have a lot to talk
about on our way home did you not see
the relationship lasting after this
after today just have to wait and see
nah
yeah there's no waiting a lot came to
light this episode
that we didn't know about
we'll discuss it slightly but
i think it's enough said at this point
so matt did you think you had told
chelsea about the cheetah even though
you hadn't
yes
yes i honestly thought that we had i
would have remembered
i would remember that
but i do have really bad memory and this
was a long time ago so
let's not forget you also cheated on
matthew right okay but we didn't have to
bring that up we were talking about him
there's always two sides to a story we
were talking about him why are you you
don't seem to care that much oh
i'm not gonna
expose myself on camera
sometimes sometimes
so we'll see you in the final guys we
see you there mate you actually better
win in the final because you're buying
me a louis bag out of that money that's
cool do you want to be more specific how
did you cheat
same as him really
commenting
oh so it's more instagram based rather
than penis vagina base yeah
it's both
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you